and so yesterday I sent out a tweet
reminding everyone that all-new
all-different marvel starts this week
and while there seem to be a lot of
interest there were also individuals who
were confused in terms of how it relates
to secret wars since the event is still
going on as well as how the titles will
be released and whether or not they will
spoil anything and so what I want to do
here is break things down and try to
provide the best answers I can so that
you have a well-rounded idea of what
you're getting into come Wednesday so in
terms of Secret Wars
according to marvel's calendar issue 6 7
& 8 are scheduled to be released over
the course of October and November and
so the question is should you read the
rest of Secret Wars in truth the answer
is that it's completely up to you I will
continue to cover the series to its
completion here on my channel but all
new Ultimate Marvel picks up eight
months after the end of Secret Wars and
so while there may be some reference to
its conclusion the purpose of all-new
all-different marvel is to keep the
histories of their various characters
intact from their stories prior to
Secret Wars up to their current launches
as well as ensure that the stories are
written in a manner that makes them a
good jumping-off point for new readers
and so while these solicitations may or
may not necessarily spoil anything
pertaining to what happened to doom
along with the various territories in
battle world at the end of Secret Wars
the stories of all-new all-different
marvel would spoil who the survivors are
coming out of Secret Wars and so again
this is largely personal preference
having said that the question becomes
where should you start for all-new
all-different marvel as a kind of
experiment here I want to focus on these
spider-man titles since they will most
likely be the highest sellers and if
this is something that proves to be
popular then I'll make videos focusing
on the Avengers the x-men Deadpool and
the miscellaneous titles that are left
over so in terms of all-new
all-different marvel as a whole the
first place I would suggest is all-new
all-different marvel point 1 as an
introductory one-shot according to
Marvel this comic will be written by Al
viewing and serves to establish the new
Marvel Universe following the 8 month
gap between the end of Secret Wars and
the launch of the new Marvel Universe
again according to Marvel this comic
will serve to provide previews for the
upcoming all-new all-different marvel
titles including daredevil carnage
agents of shield contests of Champions
and others having said that if you're
spider-man fan all-new all-different
marvel can be a little daunting since
they're launching an initial
seven titles focusing strictly on the
spider-man family and so I would suggest
starting with amazing spider-man written
by Dan Slott this comic will initially
see a version of Peter Parker who had
his mind controlled by Doctor Octopus
and a fashion similar to the events of
the pre secret war story superior
spider-man however rather than the story
transpiring in the same way instead it
will see the launch of the parker
industries conglomerate as well as set
the stage for upcoming comics belonging
to the other members of the spider
family including silk spider-man 2099
Spider Woman and spider Gwen now in
contrast to the amazing spider-man title
spider-man will focus on Miles Morales
the Ultimate Universe spider-man who's
basically been moved to the regular
Marvel Universe with all-new
all-different marvel what this means is
that with amazing spider-man focusing on
Peter Parker as an industrialist similar
to Tony Stark pre Secret Wars but
stories of Miles Morales in the
spider-man title should be more in line
with the classic tales of Peter Parker
prior to Secret Wars
conversely spider-man 2099 will see the
return of Miguel O'Hara to his signature
role under the writing of Peter David
the man who created Miguel in 1992 and
will return him to fighting crime in the
year 2099 silk will return under the
writing of Robbie Thompson with her
history in tak prior to her introduction
with Secret Wars
however the comic will initially focus
on her life and working for blackhat as
part of her gang and while the exact
nature of the relationship and how she
got into it is something we don't know
yet in an interview with claire both
resources Robbie Thompson had stated
that they would focus on this reveal
over the course of her first story arc
now Spidey
is a title that will also be written by
Robbie Thompson and will actually focus
on the time Peter Parker was a high
school and his early days as spider-man
however unlike the other spider-man
related series each issue of Spidey will
be a self-contained story and will be
suitable for all ages but it will also
be in continuity meaning that some
characters who appear in this story may
appear later in Amazing Spiderman or one
of the other spider-man related titles
now returning for spider Quinn is Jason
Latour who had written the first five
issues of following Spider Gwynn's
introduction during the original
spider-verse event prior to Secret Wars
however where the initial 5 issues were
more of a miniseries that introduced
spider-gwen swirled the all-new
all-different marvel line will see this
world expanded on although it is unknown
if this will include versions of The
Avengers the x-men and so on and finally
the last issue pertaining strictly to
the spider-man family is web warriors
focusing on spider Glen spider-ham
spider-man noir spider-man India and
spider-man UK in an interview with
marvel.com writer Mike Kosta had stated
that the story will show the group
existing as a multiversal team coming
together for the purpose of battling
enemies that threaten the multiverse and
that their first arc will focus on the
villain electro with that being said
we're gonna bring this video to an end
and let me know which one of these
titles you're looking forward to the
most and I will catch you guys later
peace